- I am very excited about your movie.
I have to lead with that.
It's also very lovely to meet you
but that just energized me so much.
I'm very excited.
I can't wait for it.
And it all started, this is what I love.
Everything started from you
tweeting this tweet in 2014.
"Hey, Marvel, great job with
Captain America and Thor.
Now how about an Asian American hero?"
So did you have any expectations
after that tweet of maybe
them possibly reaching out?
- Yeah. Yeah, for sure.
I tweeted in 2014 and I was
like a struggling actor,
I was handing out dog food samples
on the side of the road in Toronto.
And I was like, yeah, I'm going
to tweet Marvel and
it's going to be great.
They're going to read the tweet,
get back to me, offer me a role.
And so basically everything's worked
out as planned and yeah.
- That's amazing, but years later it did..
- No I had absolutely no
idea it was going to happen.
It was just kind of a
facetious thing that I tweeted
and what's happening in these
next few years has just been
pretty incredible and pretty insane.
So I'm still pinching myself
every day, to be honest.
- But after getting the part you replied
to your own tweet,
"LOL", which was awesome.
You're like, "hey, you know
what? I am Nostradamus."
- Almost to the day actually
it was July 17th and I was like
I was cast on July 21st, oh my God.
- That's crazy. - It works out.